[Music]
both candidates now working very hard to
shore up their support among women
that's the big thing in fact today they
both pledged to increase domestic
production of Ryan Gosling movies get
more because we've got to stop importing
those from the Middle East I know that's
what's been killing us yeah those
Chinese knockoff Ryan Gosling's
not they're mostly bad yeah ah people
still talking about that debate very
heated thoughts and comments about that
second debate yesterday Mitt Romney's
son tag said that during the debate he
wanted to punch President Obama for
calling his father a liar yeah he also
wants to punch his father for giving him
the name tag
and isn't he the oldest his tabs the
Olga's yes it's not like they were
running out of names
I came later and they were like Conan
first kid it'll call him tag what shall
we cook tag endorsements rolling in for
different people the national atheist
party has endorsed Barack Obama for
president yeah yeah
atheist party now we're told the news
Obama said thank God
hey another this is cool the creator of
the cartoon Dilbert announced that he is
supporting Mitt Romney yeah meat
meanwhile meanwhile the creator of
Garfield is still waiting to hear the
candidates views on lasagna and Monday's
I forget to Apple interesting news from
Apple Apple has announced that next week
it will unveil its smaller iPad the iPad
Mini exciting yeah sadly it's also
decided to rename the regular sized
model the maxy iPad
you love that no uma thurman had a
daughter uma thurman named her new baby
daughter Rosalind Arusha our Kadena Alta
loon Florence Thurman Busan in other
words uma thurman's daughter will never
be able to drink from a personalized
coffee mug she's gonna be looking at
that carousel there's not a people in
here somewhere
it's like it's like she she picked the
name out of the New Mexico Atlas Flavor
Flav is in the news ladies and gentlemen
Flavor Flav has been arrested on assault
charges if convicted he may get a prison
sentence of 10 years plus time already
worn on his chest
[Applause]
I love that you like yeah does it look
cool ah a new trend in comfort wear get
this is a new trend in comfort where is
part pyjamas part poncho and it's called
the poncho that's true yeah the guy who
invented it is called a puss stoner
exciting news out of India a 96 year old
man became the world's oldest father
yeah yeah his wife gave birth to a
beautiful 62 year old baby boy
[Applause]
a new study just came out and it finds
that every hour of TV watching every
hour of TV watching cuts 22 minutes off
your life however I promise that when
you're lying on your deathbed your last
words will be Conan was worth it
[Applause]
that was me acting out your soul leaving
your body